check this out Steve Ducey on Fox News
tried to add a little bit of common
sense to the discussion this morning on
Fox and Friends about why
lawyer
lawyers in general are able to give
testimony that is being used in the
prosecution of Donald Trump and really
they're talking about Michael Cohen
because one of the things that the right
has started to harp on is how do you
force lawyers to break attorney-client
privilege how is it Michael Cohen is
somehow being used to provide evidence
against Trump when he was Trump's lawyer
there's a very simple explanation it's
called the crime fraud exception Steve
Ducey tries to explain it to his
co-hosts they don't want to hear it when
you try to insert fact on Fox and
Friends you aren't rewarded so I think
there's a lot to fight here and in the
back of my mind in watching all this is
we could be doing this three more times
yeah we could be doing it with the
January 6th let's hope we could be doing
it with the Georgia situation and we
could do with Mar-A-Lago man just
heating up like you wouldn't believe
they are now making secret service
testify they make his own attorney uh uh
Corcoran he has to testify his own
client well what is it Jack Smith is is
somehow rocket fueled to get uh Trump in
a way that I don't I can't believe
people aren't challenging this and
saying even if I don't like Donald Trump
what's going on here because of the
crime we've talked about this the crime
fraud uh exemption if if you get legal
advice during the execution of a crime
it happens more than you would believe
talk to Mark Levin about that you're an
attorney a client privilege goes out the
window regarding the Secret Service how
many times has it happened
so two arguments first they're ignoring
the crime fraud exception then Brian
Kilmeade moves to well how often has it
actually happened we're going to address
all of these points in a moment Secret
Service and you flip them I am just
talking about what is the law that is
the law rarely used that is well it was
used in this case the other thing is if
the I feel like it's uh open the mic
night I'm getting a Heckle over here no
I'm not heckling you I'm just saying
it's so ludicrous attorney okay so
Ainsley Earhart is saying it's ludicrous
Brian kilometer saying it's ridiculous
and Steve Ducey is absolutely correct
about lawyers testifying and the crime
fraud exception it's not controversial
and it actually has been used many times
so the crime fraud exception is a legal
principle which allows certain
confidential Communications like for
example those between an attorney and
their client to be disclosed in court if
they were made to further the commission
of a crime or a fraud so if you use your
attorney-client relationship to plan or
carry out a crime or fraud then it's not
protected by attorney-client privilege
it's actually a really simple legal
principle so if you have a lawyer and
you consult with your lawyer to commit a
fraud to cover up a crime or whatever
though those conversations those
Communications could be subject to the
crime fraud exception they aren't
protected by attorney-client privilege
that is what Trump and Michael Cohen
were doing then when Steve Ducey
explains it to Brian Kilmeade
Kilmeade moves on to well it's never
used
well hold on a second it's that's it now
that is a different argument how does
Brian kilmead note that does he cover
trials enough to know whether or not
it's actually used and the answer is of
course he doesn't and the truth is that
the frequency of the crime fraud
exceptions it's difficult to determine
because it does depend on the
circumstances and it's not like there is
public uh journalism around every use of
the crime fraud exception most court
cases
aren't reported on in the way that we
would be able to say here's the
frequency of the use of the crime fraud
exception but there are some pretty
prominent examples of it being used the
Enron Scandal if you haven't read uh
what's the name of the book I think it's
the smartest guys in the room or
something like that if you haven't read
the book about the Enron Scandal I
recommend it in the early 2000s Enron
was engaging in all sorts of accounting
fraud and it led to its bankruptcy and
during the investigation that crime
fraud exception was indeed used with
regard to Communications between Enron
Executives and their lawyers because it
helped to establish those fraudulent
activities so that's a very prominent
case in which it was used the Bernie
Madoff Ponzi scheme when Bernie Madoff
was arrested for running that huge Ponzi
scheme and defrauded investors to the
tune of billions the crime fraud
exception was also used to obtain
privileged Communications between Madoff
and his lawyer and it revealed Madoff
lied to his investors and his lawyer
about the existence of the fraudulent
scheme so it is the law
and it is used including in prominent
cases kill meat is wrong Ainsley Earhart
is breathlessly out of control Steve
Ducey is the guy that's correct and on
Fox and Friends you aren't exactly
rewarded for introducing sanity and fact
as I've mentioned before I supplement my
diet with vitamins every day I've tried
different methods none have been simpler
or more cost effective than just a daily
scoop of ag-1 from our sponsor athletic
greens with the one scoop I get the 75
high quality vitamins and minerals from
whole food sources that I want I'm
covered for the day I'm not messing
around with different vitamin capsules
and then some have 200 and some have 180
so they run out at different times and
it's a mess it's a mess this is simple
The Taste is good you can put it in
water juice or shakes each serving is
under three bucks a day compare that to
what all of the individual supplements
would cost you and it just makes sense
simplify your life by starting the day
with a scoop of 75 high quality
nutrients when you go to athletic
greens.com
you'll get a free year supply of vitamin
D I've talked about vitamin D before and
five free travel packs of ag1 the link
is down below